thank you to the Salt Lakes for
welcoming us to all Hero weekend as a
special treat taverns will be open till
8 PM I've never got so many cheers I'm
so excited why Steph here everyone knows
I was brought in to replace them
he thinks he can replace me cute look
LeBron's Court in the second had his
young guard
a king you already have Dilo LeBron step
away from the impressionable young star
thanks Dave I almost had to go to a
place with pressure and expectations
I've battled too many super teams some
less super than others and I vow no
super teams will form this all Hero
weekend not just loyalty again
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
I've used it many times it's never
failed me LeBron
oh did I ruin another one of your trades
maybe it's me or maybe it's you
[Music]
Dave calm down you're not supposed to
activate it not at all Hero weekend
welcome back to the celebrity all Hero
game
goes down the court
nice beat
is game time may God have mercy on us
all
no more hand covering mouth Whispering
pain
all the way
I knew this would happen before I came
here I knew this would happen 16 volts
Dave
you're right about super teams everyone
should follow the old ways of
heartbreaking lawsuits
sorry Dane you were destroying the Salt
Lakes and none of us want to be a part
of that rebuild
wow
nice bag of tricks you got there whoa
careful no super teams
I've used it many times it's never
failed me
[Music]